自媒体怎么专钱呀 为什么我有流量 但是我赚不了钱
这条视频告诉大家 我是怎么做的
然后我就用了一个方法
然后肯定是有收益的 我会告诉大家 背后的逻辑
然后专钱打开有其中方式 其中形式 你总理条路 对吧
为什么我最后会选的这样的一个方式
然后去的操作步骤是什么样的 甚至我的条视频其实就是一个案例
老规矩 想到哪儿说哪儿
因为这个骑子是今天上午的时候 我直播的时候就有人说
孤独说 怎么样 怎么专钱啊
我这个视频对我流量 他是我赚不到一分钱
就够干红温了 所以我就上来跟他聊聊
来 先讲逻辑和道理
就很多人认为我做短视频有流量 然后就赚钱 其实不是的
一个是跟他游戏时是两部主上的 两部主上 一部是流量
流量就是有人家 让人看到你 对吧
另外一个问题就变现
就是我们现在有一个大的问题在哪呢
大的问题就是机会所有人都去保留量
保留量是什么呢 保留量就是各种奇蹟影效
对吧 可能人家心里的问题 多把案子 高屋子 是不是这样的吧
你说那个影量吗 有的影量 真的是美样 他就是流量来自于什么 流量来自于平台的算法
和用户的多把案
这个我讲的过程处吧
然后你会把案子就上去了
烧完了以后你又没有流量
但是变现来自于什么 变现来自于你给我提供的价值
什么价值 我提过的价值 我提过的意思 比如说
我是一个渡弊博主
对比我说 或者是我说什么什么 保住吧
就是我有流量 但是我做过一个渡弊博主
我卖那个南卖机 你他们都家的话就多好啊 现在卖太大华还便宜 你卖卖两块吧 你卖吧 你不会卖的
因为这个里面没有人说
换句话说 买东欲聚员什么 第一个有价值 第二你真是的信任
是不是 我买东欲不是这样子 除非那个特别便宜啊 就八毛钱一块钱 那无所谓了 对不对
我就我就
但是真的要买一个好东欲的时候
那么两条是一定要过的 一个就是我信任你
另外一个这个东西 确实值得买过 我还喜欢
对吧 我买个大价值不是这个样子吗
所以为什么视频上有什么韭汉酒 我的909了这个好卖 在多一点不好卖的原因是什么
就是这个原因
但是我怕可能就追着这个流量了 他那种里面 阳哥的说是没有真正
没有真正的传的价值 而是你
不但你卖东欲 你不看你可行 你本身就不可行 你出出传达不可行
人们当然就不会蛮假的东侠的
所以就出现了一个什么情况的 就是你流量很大
但是你其实赚不了钱的 这个我们自己老伙就都有做的就是
跟我说我就说问题 我就跟你们解释这块
所以各位建议的地方咱们总结了啊
一个短时间十多两部分出传的 一个是
就是传播
流量 流量来自于什么的来自于平台的算了 可多安
另外一部分就是
别切 别先来自于什么 别先来自于
价值和新价
好了 有了这个部分的话 我来讲的第二个 二流时候可以不讲
但是我还是跟大家简单讲的一下
我之前其实讲很多东西 大家可能没太注意
流量这个东西突然就有了 流量
但是流量有的时候 你会发现过了这个流量
其实他就不什么意了
他跟你没关系了
对吧 你就比如说你 我们有人有的一条视频破了 爆了
那以后有什么价值的 没什么价值
所以有些东西就是
瞬间计事
就谈划一些 完了以后就没有了
很多网红就这个原因吗 但是我在这个 赶紧六年了 对不对
我来到你们 赢六年了
其实你会搬运做的好
这个这么不要脸的 对不对
我一直跟大家分享 就是我要去做资产 而不是做流量
什么意思 就是做一个东西 他要能够理无处理价的
而且越级有越像 啥意思 就会这个级有一样
就是如果你做了一条内容 这个内容不是一周以后过去
他就没用了 而是
一年过去以后 还有三年过去以后 还有用 然后一年过去 还有用
我看六年过去一看 韩智亮还在上升
对不对 你看有很多老婆 你看我之前的视频
说我胡说过 你当年那个判断真的很对 你是怎么判断的
你那个判断的有效 对不对 你越起来越是 这就是此产 好了
说了这么多廢话 这是讲原理的部分
那么然后我来个大家叫什么 我就开始关注
真正有用的东西 而不是流量本身的那么这里面我做东西的时候就这个格式
什么格式 你们看我的视频
虽然流量有所价划 我跟大家讲 我不看的 我虽然流量有所价划
我的收益提什么 收益提什么 用五月来就多了
而且次产越来越疯狂 怎么做的
就是你会发现我几乎所有的视频 你们有注意看 都是这样的
一上来我就告诉你 这条视频要干嘛
来 我将你们怎么争钱
来我告诉你们怎么做啊 自别停
来我告诉你们 不会拍短片怎么拍
是不是 我一上来就是这样的 今天可以我够子的
然后但是我一上来就告诉你 这就是这条视频对你有什么就很清楚
拿过来一个看 这条视频对我用 这条视频对我没用 杀了
我跟你讲 如果一个东西对别人有用 你讲的再走高
再不 我好 再课吧 我还吃再唱
真的对他有用
他就好使用 我不想被封好 就我求了一下
我告诉你 我原来怎么怎么怎么样 后来我找到一个法法 爸爸爸爸
那明白我意思吧 我想去真实 然后如果是真实的吧
你整好与这个问题 你是不是面看去
其实我的 整个灯光是什么事 什么表达 不重要了
你最多就是怎么办
是不是 你快点 你快点 说干乎 当然会看完 吃这个落击吧
所以 第一个问题就是 我会明确的告诉你 我最要是比如讲什么
第2个部分 我一定会问你 你是不是有这样一个行动
对 你是不是有这样一个行动
你是不是一直很忙
每天加班 加班把那块专门的钱 什么原因 为什么
是 我今天会跟你说 你是不是 你是不是 你是不是
就很多人为这个高走 告诉你不是 这样什么 这叫背景
背景
然后你看我第3块有点什么 你拿我是这样 你看我最近的
你从现在往往前翻多点 我跟你讲原因
背后的逻辑基利是什么 对不对 为什么 我有两个抓不到钱
我告诉你 有两个来自于什么 从前来自于什么
是不是 然后我告诉你该怎么做
然后我给你去的方法 吃这样的嘛 就是第二个部分
就是背景 然后是基利 注意到的嘛 我告诉你怎么要干什么 这条事情可以干 把你们干嘛
第二个是 他在背景是什么 什么场景一下
然后为什么会突然入情况 背后的基利 然后马上告诉你该怎么做
好 你看往的拍照上给那时候 其实我已经告诉你了
我的文章 我的视频好 都是这个基本上 大部分是这个结果 基本上就是
我告诉你要讲什么 你能得到什么
背景是什么 再什么场景下是用
什么情况下 再说一下 不是用
背后的邏輯原因是什么 具体该怎么操作
或者是我告诉你一条方法可以干嘛
然后我来证明一下 然后来高兴巨的方法
是不是这文方法 全是干货的
是操急的
视频
可能流量 因为我不太关注那个那个情绪多办法了
所以流量可能会下来 但不要紧反而会
反而会三选 什么意思呢 九里子 一条视频
可能一百万不放这
最后成为你朋友的 成为你用户的
可能是九里子 万一千人
和你不放这两个月成十五万
少了一大多 这不是 可能少了五万一还不值
但是你为万一 你的用户非常两千人 你觉得那个东话算
是吧 因为你讲的东西是十五东西 拿过来就用
所以真正想做事 真正遇到问题的人 他就会关注你
而且这个事情才会可信
一对你的方法会用过了 用过了一个真好事
而且会用过了 然后就好事
是不是可信 你这个人就是可信 你今天有什么我说
或者说怎么做读书博主
我说的实话 我做读书博主
我今天扯得稍微点原点
我告诉你 我怎么做读书博主
我基本上看书是这样的 就是乱书我不看
浪费过时间
就让会有一些人读书 或者说我没有一本书 猛我打过出卖的特别好
然后那个回忆后律特别高 不是回忆后律就是
点书特别高 因为你有提什么
百分之十百分之二是
你也可以买 我们可以推销给你推销 对不起不看
为什么 浪费我时间经历
一本乱书 为什么花生 独一本 浪费我经历另外一个
他会影响我的口悲呀 什么叫口悲呀
我跟你讲我是什么 这是我真的要独一本书 你好 不在别的后就戴书会什么
因为书我能变别他的好怪
别的动作 我变不了 我又不能轻输使用嘛
所以我独一本书以后 不好的这张 我自己怎么看
但这本书真好 我就算好 对吧 比如说我早期给家推荐的什么
什么原则呀 什么思考快呢 什么这个
轻输了一毛电 对吧 我还能看不懂 我来说是浪费的 保电呢
小儿美呀 从来要是给家推荐这样的书
然后呢 我觉得这个真好确实好 我独得自己非常受益
我就会打了 这个书放的书上了
我连 我连
你看你们成本书见过了 直接卖过书
他又提单 我没有卖过书的
但是有的时候老婆就问一些问题
我说OK 你可以我告诉你可以看应该没说
就真的得你翻到那一届 然后讲 这本书 我还是怎么提挥的 我是怎么做的
甚至就像有个说 你 书子说那本书说的那个话来自那本书那本书他说
没错吧 对不对
于是你就会发现大家就会有一个概念什么呢 哦 书子哥 他是有偏来的
他放到书上的书 都是他自己多的好书
所以我不用介绍了 大家输货那时候都会看着
书子哥都在看那些书是不是真实的情况
有些人在里面买个人就不会带着买个很正常 对吧
大多数情况 我们中国这个人情社会 什么是人情社会
就是我在里面说获得了一些东西
东西我不会
我在南南海不是买的 对不对
然后我就在里面买了 大部分人的这个情况
所以你看我从雖然不卖书 当我每个月的收入真不少
这是第一个问题 这叫什么 这个就叫什么 这个就叫什么
信仰的 信仰是这么一点一点线力来的
好多人光光光 最后卖了获得说
他就通过五分钟见了一些人 你最多就是卖个挺快球
这六十九九九九 不能带着了 对吧
第二个问题就是什么
就是我每次分享的东西 你想一个东西
他真正有用 它有的时候他有很多背后的东西
但你一个视频 你讲三分钟五分钟 十分钟 量不得 对
你不可能讲的那么细
所以其实你们可以的一件事
我也是真讲 我不尝了一样的
但是我讲完了以后有些时候 你讲英文的更深的时候
你就会发现 还是有一些东西没有
但我有在本身跟你讲不了
因为他只有三分钟五分钟
这个东西手不受 就不尝的也得 但手不尝
是吃食用嘛
是这么个邏輯吧
就是我们我们去哪儿卖了特别好的 您尝尝
我相信我的东西好 您尝尝 多尝 尝完再买
不尝 没关 不买没关系
吃什么的做生意的道理 对不对
或者有东西不好不好吃 你想一个多软件 拿去用
你先用上一段时间 你觉得有用就就用
你没有用无所谓的 对吧
我们买了衣服 也有什么挂过来 穿了衣服 好不好 好
好了 跑 跑 跑 退费 很正常吗
这是做生意 这种这是梁的性格去过来
所以我跟大家想 就如果你只做留量的话
就是你老关注多码 老关注那些所谓的结构
我给大家讲 就是那个东西就是一周一 后两周一 后五个流量就过期了
你中间的方式通常来说只有两种 一个就是你的
就是高费 流量费 穿上几块流量费
一条是不放两条 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少 多少
那个是有鲜的 联系的 联系的这广告
这广告能够把你争到鲜 你买东西你有特别好买
你广告能够把你争到鲜 但是广告有些时候好品牌人就不着急
所以你担眼那个广告有时候还注意出问题
但是你的费用做这样 因为我之前就有一个千万级打费
千万级 说千万级就是本次两千万级 不管两个特别搞
最后做做就不做的 就是很来非常辛苦
但是也不一定能接到多好的广告
但是你看效果 门这种 就是你会发现一个什么样的结果
就是第一个 就是我们只有高贝的
就是因为我就是给你好东西
我就是怎么做就给你好东西
但是我是随刻下滑的今天一天一天一天
我不是不随随滑的 我今天就只好想着这个你随随
对吧 他的短期限制 他会有信任
他你会有人说 人热好 你会发现找你的门告
好多人找我 我只是说我不做的 我觉得浪费时间都是大平台
你明白吗 因为你的人热好
你没有 我不看我不做话
是因为我不想接 不是没单子 我的单子很多的都不接
三个 就是你的东西其实有些时候你带活就很方便
非常方便 比如说我带输我自己看输嘛
我都了解 挂那就可以买的 很好了 第四个
我刚才说了 很多都是输输
就是你三分钟五分钟 你看完我觉得很有用
但是有些东西就是很喜欢 大家就会记你的什么
看满你的什么专闹 满你的输啊 满你的输啊 满你的设许
你做产品 我也相信你啊 这才是长久的
一直 我告诉你 就算最后这些都没有
我再给大家分享一个东西 你没有没有注意到我的那个合适
我在那个合适
干什么
什么背景 什么情况 什么情况 什么情况不容易
背后园了 有什么距离这么操作
这个东西生命去 你把闻党 包括这条视频都是这样的
你把闻党提出来 它是可以直接弓行的
你把我的条闻党 你们去吃吃
跳完了以后 你跟她说 请你帮我把
食潮的 她刚才讲那个歌试提到了 我那个歌试
然后你会发现你以后拍视频前文章 进入我的歌试
特别好识 是不是 它是个就是这条可知性东西
我的每一条视频我的每条文章都是可知性的
现在是AI是来啊 你想想我现在有多少个自动目的认可知性的东西
不需要我去做的 这条文字什么 拍视频比你不快的原因
还有一个就是通过这件事
我跟你讲 我自己是实实在的
相长的
所以我们很能在想法都是错的 有一上来我
我流量 小人量怎么就多行 每天的我流量交率
其实你能变形的方式就那么两个
然后但是你不敢用我这样的方式
变形的方式偷得得多
而且就算没变形 我跟你讲 你自己是实实在在的
提什么了